ja zum Abschluss von dieser themene
Einheit Forschung und Lehre
Wissenstransfer forschungsmanagement
möchte noch ein paar Gedanken
formulieren die die Kompetenzen in den
Geisteswissenschaften betreffen das ist
ein Thema was immer häufiger behandelt
wird der
Kompetenzbegriff in der Wirtschaft in
anderen Bereichen und jetzt möchte ich
heute der Frage nachgehen wie der sich
auch für die Wissenschaft speziell für
die
Geisteswissenschaften eignet ich werde
zunächst was zum Verhältnis von
Forschung und Lehre sagen dann auf diese
Frage nach der Kompetenz eingehen und
zum Schluss die neuen Bedingungen von
Forschung und Lehre thematisieren
zunächst möchte ich auf
diesen Philosophen oder wie auch immer
man ih nennt diesen Wissenschaftler
eingehen das ist willlhelm von Humbold
und der hat diesen berühmten Satz
geprägt auch wenn er sich bei ihm nicht
wirtlich findet von der Einheit von
Forschung und Lehre hier kann man sich
fragen ob das
eine deskriptive Beobachtung der Welt
ist ob Forschung und Lehrer immer in
einer Einheit sind immer schon oder ob
es nicht ein ideales eine normative
Forderung Forschung und Lehre sollten
immer in einer Einheit sich befinden
wenn das der zweite Fall ist was ich
glaube dann stellt sich natürlich die
Frage was überhaupt Forschung und was
Lehre ist und was die Einheit von beiden
darstellt das ist nicht so leicht zu
beantworten ich möchte es auch heute gar
nicht Unternehmen ich möchte nur darf
hinweisen dass um diese Einheit zu
verstehen und zu erklären man Forschung
und Lehre als eine Praxis verstehen muss
und nicht als einen Zustand also eine
Tätigkeit auch wenn man häufig Tätigkeit
eher auf die Leere bezieht forschen ist
eine Praxis und wenn man beide als
Praktiken versteht dann kann man sie
auch viel mehr auseinander verstehen und
nicht mehr als ein
Widerspruch denken oder auch pflegen wie
man es heute häufig an hoch tut dass man
sich von der Lehre befreien möchte um
mehr Zeit für die Forschung zu haben
weil nur das dasjenige ist was einem
wissenschaftliches Renommee bringt
deswegen mein plor die Einheit von
Forschung und Lehre durch aufzuweisen
dass man sie beide als Praktiken
versteht und in einem weiteren Schritt
dass man die Forschung als Praxis aus
der Praxis der Lehre her entwickelt hier
gibt es viele historische Vorbilder ganz
zurückgehend auf die Antike Sokrates der
seine Forschung wenn man es mal so
nennen möchte immer nur im Gespräch im
didaktischen
metischen Gespräch auf dem Athena
Marktplatz
betrieben hat und das könnte uns als ein
Vorbild dafür dienen was sind jetzt
Kompetenzen ganz allgemein und speziell
mit Blick auf die Wissenschaft die
Naturwissenschaft es sind Fähigkeiten es
sind Tugenden wenn man es so will und es
sind ganz allgemein gesagt Eigenschaften
mit denen man sich in herausfordernden
Situationen behaupten kann Kompetenz da
steckt natürlich auch sowas wie
kompetitiv drin also eine Art wett
Bewerb das heißt man muss diese
Kompetenzen unter anderem aktivieren
wenn man sich bewähren möchte wenn man
auch vielleicht sich durchsetzen möchte
in Konkurrenzsituation die häufig auch
ökonomisch bedingt sind und wir werden
noch sehen dass solche Bedingungen die
Kompetenzen erfordern immer mehr auch
forschungskontexte sind und nicht mehr
rein nur ökonomische Kontexte das heißt
man kann von einer Ökonomisierung auch
des Wissenschaft system sprechend
Forschung und Lehre finden immer mehr
unter den Bedingungen der Ökonomisierung
statt das sind nicht die einzigen
Bedingungen und darauf möchte ich jetzt
zum Abschluss eingehen eine Bedingung
die immer schon der Fall war ist Raum
und Zeit was bedeutet das Forschung und
Lehre muss sich orientieren muss andere
orientieren natürlich auch uns
in Raum und Zeit es gibt Dimensionen des
Raumes und der Zeit und Forschung und
Lehre muss
dazu beitragen darin Orientierung zu
stiften das kann man ganz generell sagen
jetzt gibt's aber neue Bedingungen
innerhalb deren Forschung und Lehre
stattfindet und zwar ist es die
Bedingung der Ökonomisierung die eben
auch Kompetenzen
erfordert hier kommt eine neue Dimension
ins Spiel nämlich die Unterscheidung
zwischen quantitativen und qualitativen
Anforderungen Ökonomisierung ist häufig
Quantifizierung und hier besteht die
Problematik die Qualität nicht so
vergessen das die Herausforderung und
eine weitere Herausforderung für die
Forschung und die Lehre ist die
Technologisierung hier gibt's auch
wieder ein paar Problematiken nämlich
einerseits die Vermittlung Vers die
Autonomie Technologien vermitteln unser
Denken indem sie sich dazwischen
schieben man könnte auch sagen
Medialisierung die Medien die schieben
sich zwischen unser Denken unser Handeln
und andere Prozesse Zwischenglieder die
wir häufig auch gar nicht mehr
durchschauen man sieht das so ein
Beispiel von künstliche Intelligenz und
das steht unserem Gedanken von Autonomie
entgegen den wir häufig auch mit
Forschung und Lehre
verbinden diese Frage wird besonders
relevant angesizt der Entwicklung der
neuen künstlichen Intelligenzen und
Chatbots wenn man sie befragt nach
bestimmten Ergebnissen und eine sehr
gute Antwort geliefert bekomt kommt dann
stellt sich die Frage wie dieses System
zu diesen Erkenntnissen gelangte und
welchen Beitrag man selbst dazu noch
geleistet hat das wirklich noch einem
selbst zuzurechnen ist ob es eine Form
von Autonomie ist oder nur eine Form von
Fremdbestimmung oder vielleicht sogar
auch von digitaler unmüigkeit diese
Fragen werden uns in Zukunft noch viel
mehr befassen willlhelm von Humbold
hatte sie sicherlich nicht voraussehen
können aber sein Diktum hält auch
heutzutage Geltung dass man nämlich
Forschung Lehre als eine Einheit
verstehen sollte diese Einheit wird aber
in der heutigen Zeit viel schwieriger zu
realisieren unter den Bedingungen von
Ökonomisierung und Technologisierung
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit bis
zu einer nächsten Sendung